stillstand in der metro randale auf der
straße mit einem generalstreik
protestieren hunderttausende franzosen
gegen die geplante rentenreform
höhere spritpreise und tempolimit 120
das umweltbundesamt fordert drastische
einschnitte für das klima und was
arbeitnehmer krank macht eine studie
zeigt burnout und angstzuständen
als grund für die längsten fehlzeiten
nachrichten nicht da es heute mit
christian sievers und in allen und
willkommen bei uns heute um 7 der
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
donnerstag schön dass kristin otto auch
dabei ist für den sport das freut mich
genannt in frankreich sieht es heute so
aus keine züge keine busse keine schule
hunderttausende demonstranten auf den
straßen und dazu ein generalstreik der
das öffentliche leben fast komplett
lahmlegt proteste deren letztliche
auslöser eine geplante reform der renten
ist seit einem vierteljahrhundert schon
versucht frankreichs politik das
rentensystem zu reformieren gucken uns
das zu beginn mal an anselm stern
die franzosen gehen im schnitt mit 60 in
den ruhestand das gesetzliche
renteneintrittsalter liegt hier bei 62
jahren zum vergleich bei uns in
deutschland 67 jahre und in frankreich
gibt es haufenweise ausnahmen etwa 30
prozent der beschäftigten profitieren
davon
das ganze ist kompliziert 42
verschiedene systeme regeln die renten
etwa für freiberufler und anwälte aber
auch für viele angestellte im
öffentlichen dienst beispiel die
staatsbahn hier verabschieden sich die
mitarbeiter derzeit im schnitt mit 56
von der arbeitswelt sie bekommen dafür
durchschnittlich etwa 2600 euro rente
pro monat
fest steht dieses rentensystem ist
extrem teuer
experten zufolge fehlen in den
französischen rentenkassen schon in
sechs jahren mindestens acht milliarden
euro so und die regierung will das
rentensystem händlern und zieht sich
damit den massiven zorn der
gewerkschaften zu in frankreich geht
heute nicht mehr viel aus paris thomas
walde
vieles steht in frankreich still bei der
bahn der metro in den schulen und in
vielen krankenhäusern hier nördlich von
paris leisten die beschäftigten nur das
nötigste
wir behandeln nur notfälle wir haben uns
entschieden die onkologie zu besetzen
die krebsstation aber nicht etwa die
plastische chirurgie in nord marseille
lyon paris und anderen orts folgen mehr
als eine halbe million menschen dem
appell der gewerkschaften gegen die
rentenreform der regierung zu
protestieren
vereinzelt kommt es zu ausschreitungen
wenn unser aufruf so massiv befolgt wird
nicht nur bei den demonstrationen
sondern auch beim streik dann muss die
regierung das berücksichtigen dabei ist
bislang wenig über die inhalte der
reform bekannt nur dass von den 42
verschiedenen rentenkassen viele
abgeschafft und ein punktesystem
eingeführt werden soll ähnlich wie in
deutschland
die verhandlungen sind noch nicht
abgeschlossen und die reform noch nicht
verabschiedet worden die tür der
regierung bleibt geöffnet für
verhandlungen für regierung und
gewerkschaften geht es um viel bei
dieser auseinandersetzung die regierung
einknicken würde wäre das eine
katastrophe denn dann würde auch jede
weitere reform blockiert werden
so stellen sich beide seiten auf eine
verlängerung des streiks ein gut möglich
dass auch der eiffelturm noch etwas
geschlossen bleibt und wir gehen live
nach paris christel haas sie sind auf
der place de la nation wie ist die
situation dort im moment junge wir sind
das ist der endpunkt der großen
demonstration und sie sehen es bestimmt
hinter mir sind zahlreiche polizisten
aufmarschiert weil eben seit ungefähr 20
minuten die menschen aus diesen
demonstrationszug hier herein strömen
die stimmung ist zwischen freundlich und
angespannt es gibt leute die beschimpfen
die polizisten
es gibt leute die applaudieren es gibt
leute die sind freundlich aber ein
polizist hat mir gerade gesagt dass man
einfach diese situation schlecht
einschätzen kann und dass es jederzeit
kippen kann und es ausschreitungen geben
kann wir haben hier schon oft ein paar
böller gehört aber im augenblick bleibt
es noch ruhig es hat im verlauf des
tages und der verlauf des
demonstrationszugs einige
auseinandersetzungen gegeben weiter oben
an einem anderen platz
aber bislang ist alles relativ friedlich
dann bleibt christel noch die frage wie
lang kann das jetzt so weitergehen die
franzosen können ja so wissen wir aus
der vergangenheit auch gerne mal
wochenlang generalstreik in der tat das
könnte natürlich auch so kommen
zumindest wird der streik noch
mindestens bis zum wochenende verlängert
wenn nicht sogar noch länger und viele
demonstrationen demonstranten mit denen
wir heute gesprochen haben sagen sie
wollen so lange demonstrieren bis die
unbeliebte rentenreform ganz vom tisch
ist und das kann natürlich dauern die
regierung gibt die details erst mitte
der woche bekannt und dann wird sich
entscheiden ob es ein heißer winter wird
für makro oder nicht er ist natürlich in
einer heiklen situation denn er ist ja
angetreten als sein präsidenten das land
reformieren will und die rentenreform
ist eben das herzstück wenn er scheitert
dann verliert er sein gesicht und eben
sein symbol dass er anstatt chef ist der
das land reformiert christel hzdr paris
christel herzlichen dank und damit in
dieser sendung zu uns nach deutschland
wie positioniert sich die spd zur großen
koalition
morgen sollen ja saskia esken und
norbert walter borjans die bisher
kritiker der groko waren vom
bundesparteitag zu neuen vorsitzenden
gewählt werden
im leitantrag des spd vorstands für den
parteitag steht jetzt aber nichts von
einer abstimmung über den fortbestand
der großen koalition genauso eine
abstimmung will die partei linke
versuchen zu erzwingen
andreas opitz aufbruch in die neue zeit
das wird es gewiss in berlin steht die
spd vor einem historischen parteitag
erstmals sollen die sozialdemokraten
eine doppelspitze bekommen
wir haben uns ja bewusst entschieden
dass es nicht irgendein
zusammengewürfeltes team ist sondern
zwei sind die sich schon im prozess oder
vorm prozess gefunden haben die die
letzten wochen auch gemeinsam gemeistert
haben und teamspiel ist das worauf es
ankommt am morgen hatte das neue
führungsteam mit den parteigremien
getagt dabei stand vor allem der
gemeinsame leitantrag zur diskussion der
antrag also in dem die spd mit der union
gespräche über künftige auch neue
themenschwerpunkte führende es ist ein
guter kompromiss aber sie werden
nachvollziehen können dass es nicht die
reine lehre zahlen können dessen wovon
wir überzeugt sind das ist das wesen
eines kompromisses ein kompromiss auch
deshalb weil das duo es kann walter
borjans von früheren schärferen
forderungen gegenüber cdu/csu abgerückt
ist trotzdem soll nachgebessert werden
etwa beim klimaschutz und beim thema
investitionen
es muss weitergehen mit der frage
massiver investitionen in die
öffentliche infrastruktur
und es muss auch weitergehen mit
arbeitsmarktpolitischen entscheidungen
also etwa vor allem einen mindestlohn
von 12 euro anzustreben
und in diese richtung weiter zu arbeiten
viele parteilinke sind trotzdem sauer
sie wollen kein weiterso kein
nachbessern fordern in ihrem antrag ein
raus aus der großen koalition wir
glauben dass in einer großen koalition
wir einen erneuerungsprozess nicht
hinbekommen und um überleben zu können
als spd brauchen wir einen
erneuerungsprozess ein aufbruch in die
neue zeit die spd sucht mit neuem
personal nach neuen politischen profit
die deutsche bahn ist dieses jahr etwas
pünktlicher geworden sagt sie selbst wir
werden am ende etwa einen prozentpunkt
besser sein als im vorjahr sagt
bahnvorstand ronald pofalla die
pünktlichkeitsquote 2009 10 liege damit
im jahresdurchschnitt bei rund 76
prozent aller fernzüge ihr
selbstgestecktes ziel würde die bahn
damit knapp verfehlen als pünktlich
gelten züge die weniger als sechs
minuten zu spät kommen was sich im
straßenverkehr bei uns ändern muss um
die deutschen klimaziele zu erreichen da
hat die regierung ihre vorstellungen
aber das umweltbundesamt sagt das ist
viel zu wenig die behörde fordert
deutlich härtere maßnahmen etwa ein
tempolimit auf autobahnen von 120 km
pro stunde außerdem müsse die
pendlerpauschale wegfallen und der preis
an der tankstelle bis 2030 deutlich
steigen bei benzin um 47 und bei diesel
um 70 cent
mehr dazu von winnie heescher es wird
nicht weniger auf deutschlands straßen
nicht weniger autoverkehr nicht weniger
co2 ausstoß die klimaziele werden so
nicht erreicht sagt das umweltbundesamt
und listet deshalb drastische schritte
auf tempolimit keine pendlerpauschale
höhere spritpreise wenn wir das große
ziel vor augen haben das klima zu
schützen
dann kommen wir auch an solchen kleinen
änderungen eigenen lebensstil nicht
vorbei und ich möchte gerne das ist als
eine dekade der verkehrswerte betrachtet
wird und nicht ein ende von heute auf
morgen sondern wir müssen den menschen
reinen wein einschenken wohin soll es
gehen was unsere richtung damit wir das
ziel auch schaffen
das amt ist svenja schulze unterstellt
die umweltministerin schweigt zu den
forderungen heute aber es ist kein
geheimnis dass sie und ihr kollege
andreas scheuer beim klimaschutz weit
auseinander liegen
der verkehrsminister lässt ausrichten es
gebe bereits ein klima paket und die
bürger erneut mit verzicht verbot und
verteuerung aller bundesumweltamt in
panik zu versetzen ist der falsche
ansatz
damit steht der minister nicht alleine
die vorschläge des umweltbundesamtes
gehen aus unserer sicht an der
lebensrealität vieler menschen vorbei
weil sie eben nicht die möglichkeit
haben oft massive verteuerung auf
öffentlichen verkehr oder auch schon auf
alternative antriebe auszuweichen
der verkehr hat von allen bereichen
nicht schlechteste klimabilanz der
missionen sind seit 1990 kaum
zurückgegangen und für zwanzig dreißig
hat die bundesregierung sich ein
ehrgeiziges ziel gesetzt
das umweltbundesamt eine behörde dieser
bundesregierung zeigt rote karte an den
bundesverkehrsminister den seine
vorschläge werden die klimaschutzziele
nicht erreichen dass die ideen des
umweltbundesamtes gesetzt werden ist
derzeit unwahrscheinlich wiedervorlage
möglicherweise bei der nächsten
klimabilanz
das amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen us
präsident donald trump ist ein
entscheidendes stück näher gerückt das
us-repräsentantenhaus in der hand der
demokraten arbeitet jetzt konkrete
anklagepunkte gegen den präsidenten aus
begründung trump habe sein amt
missbraucht und die nationale sicherheit
untergraben
der schritt ist eine wichtige
voraussetzung für ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen trump aus
washington ines trams rückkehr am abend
vom nato gipfel in london zurück in
washington erwartet präsident trump ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren die demokraten
im abgeordnetenhaus sie machen ernst
ihre vorsitzende fordert nun den
justizausschuss auf die anklageschrift
gegen tom zu entwerfen
unsere demokratie steht auf dem spiel
der präsident lässt uns keine andere
wahl als zu handeln er hat erneut
versucht unsere wahlen zu seinem vorteil
zu korrumpieren und so rufe ich nun den
justizausschuss auf die anklagepunkte
vorzubereiten
am dienstag hatte der
geheimdienstausschuss seinen bericht
vorgelegt nachdem er wochenlang
ermittelt und zeugen vernommen hatte die
bilanz trump habe sein amt missbraucht
indem er den ukrainischen präsidenten
gedrängt habe ermittlungen gegen einen
politischen rivalen von trump
einzuleiten jump gibt sich kämpferisch
diese nichtsnutz twittert er diese
radikal linken demokraten wollen mich
wegen nichts des amtes entheben das gute
aber ist die republikaner sind vereinter
denn je wir werden gewinnen
trump könnte recht behalten denn ob er
tatsächlich das weiße haus verlassen
muss entscheidet letztlich der senat
dort haben trans republikaner die
mehrheit und die lassen ihn erst fallen
wenn sich die öffentliche meinung gegen
ihn wendet das ist derzeit noch nicht
abzusehen krams rechtsberater so hört
man aus dem weißen haus wollen wenn das
amtsenthebungsverfahren voraussichtlich
im januar im senat landet aggressiv auf
angriff gehen anders als im
abgeordnetenhaus haben dort die
republikaner die regie und können das
verfahren bestimmen
seit jahren steht der unkrautvernichter
glyphosat in der kritik weil er
möglicherweise krebserregend ist
glyphosat ist ein produkt der firma
monsanto die mittlerweile zum deutschen
bayer konnte
angehört und jetzt kommt heraus monsanto
hat zwei wissenschaftliche studien die
für das image von glyphosat positiv
ausgegangen waren
selbst mit finanziert der verein
lobbycontrol deckt jetzt auf der autor
der deutschen gutachten ein
wissenschaftler an der uni gießen und
sachverständiger für das
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium hatte
auch von monsanto geld für die studien
bekommen und das in keinem seiner werke
angegeben
und jetzt eine aufrüttelnde statistik
aus deutschland immer mehr beschäftigte
melden sich krank
die versicherten der
betriebskrankenkassen fehlten im schnitt
18,5 tage am häufigsten blieben
arbeitnehmer wegen rückenschmerzen hat
rose und gelenkschmerzen zu hause knapp
jeder sechste hatte grippe oder husten
also atemwegserkrankungen und gleich
dahinter burnout angstzustände also
psychisch bedingte krankheiten und
gerade hier gibt es die meisten fehltage
37 im jahr je nach rom hat ein beispiel
seine psychische erkrankung zu
verheimlichen kostete thorsten stelter
unheimlich viel kraft 2011 erkrankte der
42-jährige jurist an einer depression
am arbeitsplatz in einer
mittelständischen kanzlei versuchte er
immer wieder gegenüber seinen mandanten
stark aufzutreten und die krankheit zu
überspielen in wirklichkeit bin ich ganz
schwach gewesen damals und ich konnte
diese schwäche aber nicht nach außen hin
zeigen weil ich einfach auch angst hatte
unheimlich angst den job zu verlieren
unheimliche angst mein umfeld zu
verlieren
ich wollte damit auch keinen belasten
die zahl der psychisch erkrankten ist
über die jahre zwar gleich geblieben
aber sie werden heute schneller erkannt
als früher so der aktuelle
gesundheitsbericht der
betriebskrankenkassen
deshalb haben sich zwischen 2008 und
2010 die anzahl der fehltage aufgrund
psychischer erkrankungen mehr als
verdoppelt fast jeder sechste viel tag
geht auf eine psychische störung zurück
am stärksten betroffen sind berufe in
den branchen dienstleistungen und
gesundheit
in den sozial- und gesundheitsberufen
herrscht zum einen fachkräftemangel dh
die arbeit ist hoch verdichtet man hat
kaum die chance pausen zu machen und man
hat keine chance abstand von der arbeit
zu gewinnen
im gegenteil man identifiziert sich mit
den sozialen den gesundheitlichen
problemen der klienten dann werden sie
irgendwann die eigene thorsten stellte
hat sich dazu entschieden seinem neuen
arbeitgeber von seiner depression zu
erzählen
ein offener dialog sei wichtig um
gemeinsam eine lösung am arbeitsplatz zu
finden macht nachdenklich
jetzt sind wir beim sport während die
sendung mit frankreich begonnen du musst
in frankreich weiter
die ja eigentlich schon aber erstmal
nach schweden östersund dort bestimmen
die biathleten und da sehen wir bei
frankreich aus frankreich das geschehen
am tag nach dem vierfach erfolg bei den
herren landeten auch zwei französinnen
auf dem podest über 15 kilometer der
damen die deutschen starterinnen
verfehlten die top ten
franziska preußler gibt ihre chancen auf
eine bessere platzierung beim letzten
schießen leistet sich dort einen
weiteren fehler insgesamt bei 20 schoss
drei fehler am ende rang zwölf und damit
letzte deutschland
naja ich bisschen schade reihe ist wer
hat schon was möglich gewesen aber ich
denke für drei fehler
ja da kommen einfach nicht mehr erwarten
im einzel tränen der freude bei der
siegerin justine presov nach ihrem
debakel im sprint mit sechs fehlern
leistet sich die junge französin heute
nur zwei fehler dazu die drittbeste
laufzeit das wird mit platz eins belohnt
vor der fehlerfreien schützen aus der
ukraine julia britta die
mannschaftskollegin von bresser julian
simon
unterm strich erneut ein äußerst
erfolgreicher wettkampf für das team
frankreichs zur fußball-bundesliga
erstmalig seit 43 jahren empfängt
borussia mönchengladbach als
tabellenführer bayern münchen und könnte
mit einem sieg den abstand auf den
rekordmeister auf sieben punkte
anwachsen lassen
seit gut zwei monaten steht die borussia
an der spitze so konstant stark spielten
die fohlen zuletzt in den 70er jahren
unter trainer legende hennes weisweiler
der heute 100 jahre alt geworden wäre
fünf heimsiege in serie haben das
selbstvertrauen der gladbacher weiter
gesteigert sind keine lautsprecher aber
wissen sicherlich auch keine mannschaft
und kein verein der sich in irgendeiner
form versuch klein zu machen sondern wir
wollen am wochenende das spiel hier zu
hause gewinnen die bayern kommen trotz
der heimniederlage gegen leverkusen mit
ansteigender formkurve
ich glaube dass bayern gerade wieder am
weg sind diese natürliche autorität
zurückzufinden
dieses mir san mir das beste team der
letzten jahrzehnte gegen den
tabellenführer ein echtes spitzenspiel
und alles dazu am samstagabend im
aktuellen sportstudio christin bewusst
es kaum glauben wir haben nochmal
frankreich jetzt wie wichtig und wie
schön licht ist das merken wir gerade in
der weihnachtszeit und besonders groß
ist die wirkung jetzt gerade in new york
zu einem spektakulären lichterfest
kommen dort jedes jahr millionen
besucher aus plätzen und fassaden
werden faszinierende kunstwerke aus
licht und musik heute geht's los
allerdings nur noch bis kommenden
sonntag
wir sollten ein bisschen beeilen wenn
wir dahin wollen gefrierenden regen
braucht wirklich kein mensch aber morgen
gibt es ihn bei manchen zumindest
erklärt gleich katja horne für die
anderen bekommen teilweise nebel sonne
oder sturm im fernsehen und im netz
bekommen sie das heute journal mit dem
kollegen claus kleber um 21 uhr 45
morgen gibt es uns wieder danke für
heute in einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren heute
kamen im nordwesten bereits dichtere
wolken an viele hatten auch strahlenden
sonnenschein und es gab nebelfelder zum
beispiel in bayern auch an der donau in
baden württemberg am bodensee und
entlang des rheins und in diesem nebel
da gibt es sehr kalter lagen die
höchsttemperaturen am nachmittag bei
frostigen minus 3 bis minus 1 grad mit
sonne allerdings ging es immerhin auf
vier bis acht grad drauf heute nachts
sinken die werte meist auf minus ein bis
minus 7 grad es kann also glatt sein
nicht so im nordwesten da liegen die
tiefsttemperaturen bei 5 bis 2 grad dort
kommt regen heran und es wird sehr
stürmisch in süddeutschland gibt es
wieder nebel genauso wie in den
vergangenen nächten ja und morgen wird
es dann spannend die höchsttemperaturen
liegen zwar zwischen 1 und 10 grad
aber vormittags bleibt das besonders in
der mitte deutschlands lange kalt dann
geht es los mit dem wettlauf zwischen
den milderen temperaturen und dem regen
und wenn der regen gewinnt dann fällt er
auf gefrorenen boden es gibt
gefrierenden regen besonders in
thüringen hessen rheinland pfalz und im
saarland am längsten sonnig bleibt es
morgen in sachsen und in bayern und das
wochenende wird dann doch sehr
durchwachsen und windig kälter wird es
in der nächsten woche nahm noch